[Music]
zach
is with us in houston hi zach how are
you
i'm doing fine how are y'all today
better than we deserve what's up
awesome i got a question for both of
y'all i am looking for advice
so it is solicited he's been listening
it was a great segment by the way um for
my living situation
i am in between either buying a home or
getting an apartment
um with this housing market the way it
is i don't know if i should jump on the
bandwagon and try to outbid somebody
like others i've seen been doing
or if i should just wait till it cools
off and
go from there how much do you have saved
i have 65 000 saved in a
an account then i also have
140 in investments
thanks to the smart investor pro program
so thank you dave and your team
cool the investments are retirement
accounts like roth and so on
uh yes mutual funds um some retirement
stuff i rolled into an ira
but it's all all in some kind of a
retirement or some of it in just
miscellaneous mutual funds
uh both mostly in mutual funds
okay i'm gonna try one more time because
i'm still confused it should all be in
mutual funds
but okay is is it not in roth and iras
of some kind i'm sorry it is raw
okay all of that it should be i was
thinking it was okay so you don't have
anything that you can cash out of
investments without retirement penalties
right
incorrect i have about 50 of that that i
put cash towards
that i could pull out whenever i wanted
okay that's not in a roth ira or
not in an ira of any kind okay
is that what you're saying i believe so
yes okay then i would use that 50 and i
would use this 65 together
for your down payment i don't put as
much down on this house that does not
cash out retirement to put down
now okay here's the thing and you're out
of debt and you have your emergency fund
right
the only debt i have is about 17 000
towards a truck
we have to pay that off before we can
have this discussion okay
so when you get off the phone go pay
that off okay um then then we're going
to take the
uh what's remaining with your you're not
about a hundred thousand roughly to
to put down a house then between the 50
and the 50
65 minus 17. and you've got an emergency
fund
the 65 includes that emergency oh my
gosh so we don't have that either okay
all right so we got to break that out so
your your three to six months of
expenses is set aside
and you've got 48 000 of the 65 left
because we just paid your truck off
and you you finish your emergency
because we don't buy we do not recommend
buying a house until you're debt-free
and have the emergency fund so that's
where we're trying to get you to
okay which you can be there with what
you have you just need to think about it
differently and allocate it differently
and not use that towards your down
payment is what we're saying
exactly and so let's just say we put 20
000 bucks in the
emergency fund just for the fun of it
okay okay so out of 65 minus 17
minus 20 that's gonna leave you 28 there
50 in investments that's not in
retirement funds of any kind
would be 78 that you've got for a down
payment on a house with a fully funded
emergency fund and no truck payment
you with me yes sir that's where we
would take you to
and then if you want to go buy a house
that's fine
but what you want to avoid is uh the
land of stupid and crazy
and most of what's going on out there
right now is the land of stupid and
crazy
so you just want to go looking at houses
and if you can buy one
and not feel like you were a nut job
when you bought it
then then go ahead and buy it right
there's nothing to say you can't
buy in this market but what you don't
want to do is get caught up
in this thing where you're paying a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars
more for a house than it's worth because
a whole bunch of goobs lined up on the
sidewalk and at an auction
right okay so you know you go make an
offer on a house and if you don't get it
that's fine and
you just don't feel the pressure and you
don't get the house fever
and you wander around and kind of take
your time and
if you can sneak up on one fine or if
you get frustrated with the whole
process and want to just wait
that's okay too but you there's just
don't what you're saying is
i don't want to participate in crazy and
i'm agreeing with you
mm-hmm so but that doesn't mean you
can't find somebody to sell a house in
in houston texas it's possible and the
market has cooled in the last 30 days
over what it was in most markets it was
just about 30 days ago was probably the
apex
and uh it was the first time in since
we've kept records in the real estate
world
that are accessible that over half of
the houses that sold sold for
more than asking price and that was 60
days ago
and it's gone down since then and so
it's just it's
not it's still crazy still crazy but
it's not anywhere near as crazy as two
months ago i had a question dave for all
the people listening right now that are
in that position where they're either
buying their
i guess mostly probably buying their
first home maybe buying you know
a different house or moving how do you
discern am i being a nut job or not
because i think a lot of people
especially someone you know that like
zach that he's buying his first home
how much is how what is reasonable what
is too much because we've talked before
about
you know the demand dictates the price
and so someone's willing to pay it you
know this is the new value this is the
new price point
if someone's listing right now and they
want to buy a house how do they discern
okay this is this is a normal
competitive good
thing to offer and this is now getting
into the land of crazy do you have any
type of parameters to help people
discern that
because this is so scary for a lot of
people right now
well i mean okay number one anytime
you're doing something new buying a
house you've never bought before it's
gonna feel a little scary
sure whatever you do yeah that's not the
kind of scary i'm talking about
but i think most of us know when we're
out of control in a frenzied
buying mode you know it's almost like a
manic
thing like a manic depressive like a
bipolar thing and we all have that
little thing
i mean i know when i have bought stuff
when there was nothing going to keep me
from buying it i was like an addict
you know what i mean and i think if you
got that if you're in that gear
you know you need to stop and back away
and that's
that it may not even be the price it may
just be a spiritual thing that you're
not supposed to do that right now
because if you're getting in that manic
gear in that gear where
nothing can keep me from from my housing
fix
like you're a freaking addict or
something you got house fever yeah
and and that's when these people are
going that's when they're going to wake
up with regret on the back of their
tongue
you know they're going to wake up with a
financial hangover
having bought the house and it's not
necessarily oh you paid 22 percent more
there's not a formula okay but you you
kind of know
that you're out of control you know i
mean
i can't even remember going in freaking
costco and there's too much stuff in the
buggy yeah you know i'm just out of
control
yeah and and it it's it's your trip to
gear there
it's not just okay this is a systematic
methodical
reasonable wise purchase
so you're saying more check in with
yourself it's less about the house and
the price
than it is like what's going on because
i don't think there is a formula on the
house or the price
yeah i mean obviously if you go way
up over the value of the asking price
and any comps in the area and you're
going to pay 40
more than it's ever appraised for before
you're probably in the stupid land i
mean
oh and how can you even be excited about
that because you're just the one that
paid more
like it's like it's like yeah you got it
but you're also just the highest bidder
it usually has to do with they're moving
from a very expensive market to a less
expensive market so they
perceive value right there that's not
there
okay like california people coming to
nashville i mean we see that a ton yeah
you move out of uh
you know you move out of silicon valley
and you move to abilene texas my god you
can buy half the town yeah with when you
sold your house
you know and so but that doesn't mean
you should right
that doesn't mean it's a good buy it
doesn't mean you're not going to be able
to resell it
right after you do that because but the
real estate prices are just so
different that it emotionally just lets
you get out of control
yeah and so you've got to use just some
methodical
okay here's what the house appraises for
with comps
the the market's really hot so it's
probably worth a little bit more than
that
uh really i mean it really might
appraise because there's a heat on the
thing
supply and demand but it's not worth 34
more yeah
gotcha i mean you know we're going to
take a 500 000 house and pay
750 for it and call that wise right
that that appraised a month ago for 500
right
right right there's we're not in hyper
inflation here yes
so it's a range you're kind of looking
that's just your brain going into attic
mode
and you've got house fever yeah and you
gotta you gotta just
we all can do it i can do it i can sense
myself doing it and i have to just go
whoa
i'm managing god's money here i gotta
report to him how i'm doing this
and he's not going to like my attitude i
got to fix this